je pense que vous savez qu'on vit dans
un monde qui a un petit problème avec
l'énergie entre l'épuisement des
énergies fossiles et bien sûr le
réchauffement climatique causé par les
gaz à effet de serre nous vivons en ce
moment une crise énergétique
d'ailleurs on l'entend assez souvent un
il faut économiser l'énergie éviter d'en
dépenser inutilement et trouver d'autres
façons d'en produire mais là il ya un
truc que je comprends pas j'ai appris en
cours de physique que l'énergie est une
quantité qui est toujours conservée on
peut pas créer d'énergie on ne peut pas
en détruire non plus c'est un des
principes les plus fondamentaux de la
physique à l'énergie se conserve alors
pourquoi on parle de l'économiser et
bien pour comprendre ça il va falloir
parler un peu de thermodynamique miam
miam
et vous allez voir que le problème ce
n'est pas l'énergie mais l'entropie
[Musique]
l'énergie est une propriété que possède
tous les cores physiques du plus petit
au plus grand et qui peut exister sous
différentes formes
on a par exemple l'énergie cinétique qui
est lié au fait qu'un objet soit en
mouvement
cette énergie dépend de la masse et de
la vitesse de l'objet on a une formule
pour ça et plus l'objet est massif et
rapide plus il possède d'énergie
cinétique
par exemple il ya à peu près autant
d'énergie cinétique dans une rame de tgv
lancé à pleine vitesse que dans un
supertanker naviguant à 10 kilomètres
heure mais ya pas que ça il ya aussi
l'énergie potentielle de pesanteurs qui
est associée au fait qu'un objet se
trouve dans un champ de gravité dans
lequel ils puissent tomber
elle dépend là aussi de la masse de
l'altitude de l'objet et de l'intensité
de la pesanteur
il existe encore d'autres formes
d'énergie qui nous sont plus ou moins
familière dans notre quotidien
l'énergie chimique celle qui associée
par exemple à du carburant l'énergie
électrique ou encore l'énergie nucléaire
ce qui est important c'est qu'un corps
physique peut posséder de l'énergie sous
plusieurs de ses formes et l'énergie
peut même changer de forme alors prenons
un exemple simple imaginez un boulet de
1 kg placé au sommet d'une falaise de 10
mètres au bord d'une plage
si on maintient le boulet immobile sa
vitesse est nul il n'a pas d'énergie
cinétique
mais en revanche il a de l'énergie
potentielle de pesanteur associé à son
altitude maintenant supposer que je
lâche le boulet il va se mettre à chuter
perdre progressivement de l'altitude et
donc perdre de l'énergie potentielle
mais en échange il va gagner de la
vitesse et donc de l'énergie cinétique
et comme l'énergie totale du boulès
conserve la quantité d'énergie qu'il
possède est constante mais sa forme
varie elle devient de plus en plus
cinétique est de moins en moins
potentiel il ya un transfert d'une forme
d'énergie à une autre et d'ailleurs on
peut même avec ce principe calculer la
vitesse kora le boulet à la fin de sa
chute un environ 14 mètres par seconde
alors ça c'est très bien mais juste
après quand le boulet touche le sable et
s'immobilise et là il est à une altitude
nul plus d'énergie potentielles et à une
vitesse nul plus d'énergie cinétique
alors allez passer ou l'énergie eh bien
elle n'a pas disparu elle s'est
transformée en chaleur quand on a un
choc comme celui du boulet sur le sol
l'énergie cinétique est dissipée évacué
sous forme de chaleur à cause de tous
les frottements et les déformations qui
vont freiner le boulet
au moment du choc à notre échelle cette
chaleur dégagée est assez imperceptible
imaginons que le boulet récupère toute
cette chaleur et bien ça lui causerait
une augmentation de température de
seulement 0,1 degré cette légère
élévation de température correspond à
une forme d'énergie qu'on appelle
l'énergie thermique et de même qu'on a
vu que l'énergie cinétique peut devenir
potentiel eh bien elle peut aussi se
transformer en énergie thermique
c'est ce qui se passe quand le boulet
heurte le sol pour bien comprendre
comment ça se produit prenons un cas un
peu différent de celui du boulet
imaginez un skieur en route d'une pente
au départ il est immobile il ne possède
pas d'énergie cinétique
mais il a une énergie potentielle quand
il s'élance sur la pente son énergie
potentielle se transforme
progressivement en énergie cinétique
mais cette dernière à cause des
frottements de la neige et de l'air se
transforme à son tour en énergie
thermique
arrivé au pied de la pente l'énergie
potentielle du skieur est nul mais il
lui reste de l'élan donc de l'énergie
cinétique qui au fur et à mesure du
ralentissement par les frottements va
peu à peu se transformer en énergie
thermique est donc tout au long de cette
trajectoire la composition de l'énergie
du skieur varie entre les différentes
formes cinétique potentiel et thermique
mais la quantité totale d'énergie reste
la même les constantes cette situation
un peu idéalisée illustre un aspect de
ce qu'on appelle le premier principe de
la thermodynamique dans un système isolé
l'énergie totale et conservé deux
petites précisions avant d'aller plus
loin
j'ai parlé des frottement de l'air pour
le skieur est évidemment dans le cas du
boulet il y en a aussi un petit peu mais
pour faire simple on peut les négliger
l'autre point important avoir en tête
c'est que je les dis l'énergie se
conservent pour un système isolé en
pratique dans les situations que j'ai
décrite ça n'est pas vraiment le cas
si le skieur s'échauffent très
légèrement du fait des frottements une
partie de son énergie devient thermique
mais celle ci va être partagée avec
l'air et la neige qui vont aussi
légèrement s'échauffer pourquoi résumé
l'énergie existe sous différentes formes
elle peut passer d'une forme à une autre
dans un corps physique mais si celui ci
est isolé
la quantité totale ne bouge pas
l'énergie et conservez vous avez
peut-être que l'énergie se mesure en
joue lundi
du physicien anglais james foules et
c'est la même unité quelle que soit la
forme de l'énergie si vous avez un
skieur de disons 100 kg et que vous
voulez lui fils est allé un million de
joules vous avez plusieurs options soit
vous l'emmenez à 1000 mètres d'altitude
il aura un million de joules d'énergie
potentielles soit vous le propulser à
140 mètres par seconde à environ 500
kilomètres heure il aura un million de
joules d'énergie cinétique
soit vous élever sa température globale
d'environ 3 degrés alors une autre
solution encore consiste à lui apporter
cette énergie sous forme chimique et lui
faire manger l'équivalent de 100 grammes
de pain dans toutes ces situations ça
fait un million de joules alors comme
ses formes d'énergie se mesure avec la
même unité comme elles peuvent se
transformer l'une dans l'autre
on pourrait penser qu'elles sont
essentiellement équivalente eh bien non
malheureusement pour faire très simple
on peut diviser ses différentes formes
d'énergie en deux catégories les formes
utile et les formes inutile parmi les
formes utile et bien il ya les énergie
cinétique potentiel chimiques
électriques etc et les formes inutile
ben y'en a qu'une c'est l'énergie
thermique une forme utile d'énergie
c'est celle qui permet de faire du
travail alors faire du travail en
physique ça a un sens assez précis et ça
signifie exercer une force qui déplace
un objet prenez mon skieurs à 1000
mètres d'altitude 1 on peut imaginer le
faire descendre par une corde avec une
poulie et l'utiliser comme contrepoids
pour faire monter une charge bien si je
le fais aller à 500 km heure je peux
l'envoyer sur une bascule qui va
propulser un autre objet ou encore si je
lui ai donné des pâtes et bien je peux
lui demander de se fatiguer un peu et de
déplacer un objet dans tous les cas on
peut utiliser ses formes d'énergie pour
faire du travail
mais si j'ai uniquement chauffer mon
skieurs si je lui ai simplement donner
de l'énergie thermique et bien je ne
peux rien faire je veux pas m'en servir
pour faire bouger des choses y compris
lui-même d'ailleurs et je ne peux par
transformer cette énergie thermique en
une autre forme d'énergie cinétique ou
potentiels c'est de l'énergie en quelque
sorte inutilisable et donc quand on
regarde toutes les formes d'énergie
possédée par un corps physique on peut
séparer cette énergie thermique
inutilisable de toutes les autres formes
d'énergie utile la somme d énergie utile
on la note f
et on l'appelle l'énergie
libre parce qu'on peut en disposer pour
faire des trucs du travail pour
quantifier l'énergie inutile on
introduit une petite notion
supplémentaires si on divise cette
énergie par la température on obtient ce
qu'on appelle l'entropie du corps noté s
est donc l'énergie inutile c'est
l'entropie fois la température plus
l'entropie est élevé plus l'énergie
inutile d'un corps est élevé ce qu'on a
vu c'est que l'énergie utile pouvait se
transformer en énergie thermique mais
jamais l inverse on ne peut pas revenir
en arrière et c'est une manifestation de
ce qu'on appelle le second principe de
la thermodynamique l'entropie d'un corps
isolé ne peut qu'augmenter
on peut passer d'une forme d'énergie
utile à une autre par exemple quand vous
pédalez pour recharger la batterie de
votre téléphone et bien l'énergie
chimique stockées dans votre corps se
transforme en énergie mécanique de vos
muscles qui se transforme en énergie
électrique qui se transforme à son tour
en une autre forme d'énergie chimique
celle des batteries mais de l'énergie
thermique vers les autres formes c'est
non car l'entropie ne peut qu'augmenter
et j'espère que vous voyez en quoi c'est
relié à notre idée de crise énergétique
quand on consomme de l'énergie en fait
on la détruit par ne la fait pas
disparaître mais on la transforme on l'a
converti le plus souvent en énergie
thermique
une énergie inutilisable ensuite qu'on
ne peut pas recycler d'une certaine
façon l'entropie mesure la qualité de
l'énergie d'un corps et comme elle ne
peut qu'augmenter même si l'énergie se
conserve et bien sa qualité son utilité
ne peut que se dégrader et donc ce qu'on
appelle la crise énergétique est d'un
point de vue de pure physique
ok en fait une crise de l'entropie le
problème en théorie ça n'est pas le
manque ou la disparition d'énergie mais
l'augmentation de l'entropie alors à ce
stade il ya peut-être quelque chose qui
vous rend sceptique dans ce que je vous
raconte un je vous dis qu'on ne peut pas
transformer d'énergie thermique en
énergie mécanique par exemple et
pourtant c'est ce qu'on fait tous les
jours avec certains moteurs prenez un
moteur électrique un converti de
l'énergie électrique en énergie
mécanique éventuellement on a un peu de
perte de chaleur mais rien d'essentiel
mais un moteur à essence même une simple
machine à vapeur
on brûle un combustible on passe donc
d'énergie
chimique a de l'énergie thermique et
ensuite on se sert de l'énergie
thermique pour faire de l'énergie
mécanique
donc on peut transformer l'énergie
thermique en énergie utile faire baisser
l'entropie et bien non seulement en
apparence
souvenez vous d'un point essentiel le
second principe de la thermodynamique
nous dit que l'entropie d'un système
isolé ne peut qu'augmenter isoler le
système un moteur électrique vous pouvez
l'isoler du monde extérieur et il
transformera quand même son énergie
électrique en énergie mécanique a pas de
problème mais un moteur thermique
ils dégagent de la chaleur et il a
besoin de refroidir pas juste pour
éviter la surchauffe 1 mais d'un point
de vue est essentielle et fondamentale
dans un cycle thermique de moteurs à
combustion
il y à un moment où la chaleur engendrée
doit être expulsé vers le monde
extérieur pour que le cycle puisse
reprendre donc à moteur thermique n'est
pas un système isolé il arrive à
fonctionner parce qu'en fait ils
refilent au monde extérieur sont en
augmentation d'entreprise mais si on
prend l'ensemble le moteur et le monde
extérieur théière l'univers tout entier
en gros on a par définition un système
isolé et son entropie ne peut
qu'augmenter et donc chaque fois que
vous allumez un moteur thermique vous
augmentez l'entropie de l'univers
pensez-y un peu bande d'irresponsables
pour illustrer le fait que l'entropie ne
peut qu'augmenter et donc l'énergie
thermique ne peut pas se retransformer
en énergie utile mon père m'a raconté
qu'un de ses profs disaient la chose
suivante si vous descendez une rampe
d'escalier à califourchon
vous constaterez incertaine échauffement
de votre postérieur
par contre c'est pas en vous chauffant
le cube vous allez remonter 1,1 point
pour finir parce que je vous assènent
les principes de la thermodynamique
comme s'ils étaient les dix
commandements mais vous vous demandez
peut-être d'où vient la possibilité de
convertir de l'énergie thermique en
énergie utile et bien on peut en donner
une petite compréhension au niveau
microscopique quand on chauffe un objet
un coup on augmente la température on
augmente en réalité la vitesse
d'agitation des atomes qui le
constituent et oui car au niveau
microscopique les atomes qui composent
un solide oscille autour de leurs
positions à des vitesses assez élevé 1
qui peuvent être de quelques centaines
de mètres par seconde
et quand on augmente leur température en
fait on augmente ses vitesses
d'agitation l'énergie thermique c'est
donc en fait une forme microscopique
d'énergie cinétique
mais là
différence avec l'énergie cinétique
macroscopique c'est l'organisation
quand vous propulser un objet à une
certaine vitesse ou lui donner une
direction donnée et les atomes se
déplacent de façon cohérente 1 organisé
au contraire quand vous chauffer certes
vous augmenter la vitesse de vibrations
de chaque atome mais d'une manière
désordonnée incohérente un pas de la
même façon pour tout le monde
d'un côté vous avez une forme d'énergie
cinétique bien d'ordonner est donc utile
est récupérable et de l'autre bas c'est
le bordel on peut rien faire et c'est
pour ça qu'on associe souvent la notion
d'entropie à celle de désordre
l'entropie d'un système peut être vu
comme une mesure de son désordre au
niveau microscopique
c'est ce qui rend d'ailleurs
l'entreprise si intéressante est subtile
c'est que c'est une notion qui s'est
construite historiquement de différents
points de vue initialement le point de
vue des ingénieurs qui construisaient
des machines thermiques comme sadi
carnot puis le point de vue des
physiciens statisticiens qui
s'intéressait à l'état microscopique de
la matière comme par exemple ludwig
boltzmann et enfin plus récemment des
mathématiciens comme claude shannon qui
l'ont regardé sous l'angle de la théorie
de l'information
on pourrait parler longtemps l'entropie
remet on va s'arrêter là pour
aujourd'hui
j'y reviendrai peut-être un jour
notamment pour parler du fait que les
êtres vivants sont des machines à faire
baisser localement l'entropie et
d'ailleurs je n'ai pas une collab sur le
sujet merci d'avoir suivi la vidéo
abonnez-vous la cloche tout ça et je
vous dis j'espère à bientôt pour
vidéo pleine de science
[Musique]